the next update for plants vs zombies
garden warfare is suburban ation we're
very very excited about it it's a huge
DLC pack for us it's gonna have a brand
new map called crash course it's
basically a desert style suburbia on one
side of the map and a golf course on the
other side but to make things
interesting
the zombies decided to crash-land their
zomboss blimp right in the middle of the
map it's got a nice bridge directly in
the middle which players have to cross
and actually have to capture point
underneath the bridge and there's sniper
points on either side of the bridge and
valley that are great for range players
to take down the game mode suburban
ation is our take on a classic
domination style game mode where the
plants and zombies are fighting for
control of three strategic locations in
a map so once you actually capture all
three bases for your team you put the
other team in a sort of state of
suburban ation as we call it and that's
basically you have the other team in
complete lockdown mode and they have to
try to get at least one objective back
from you otherwise your team is just
gonna sit back and just earn lots of
coins our community is fantastic they've
been super supportive and vocal and we
were thinking of ways to include them in
a design process more so we held a
contest to vote on the new peashooter
design we took in hundreds of
submissions of concept art and cool
characters that people had created we
narrowed that down to a smaller field
voted on those internally and the
present' of the top picks onto facebook
for fans to vote the character that was
selected was called the plasma pea
shooter he sort of got a cosmic flavor
to him his weapon is very similar to the
future cactus where he can fire off a
bunch of quick you know plasma peepers
but he can hold and charge it for like
the ultimate plasma bust it's also gonna
have a bunch of new enhancements to
garden ops one of the bosses in suburban
Asian DLC is Baron von bats we're very
excited about this character he is
basically a Victorian era
vampire and he can sort of like dog
around and Wharf and disappear and come
out of nowhere you can also summon
little zombie minions that fight for
them so you mix all of that together and
we think we've got this really crazy new
boss that we think everybody's just
gonna love playing against in addition
to that literally somewhere in the world
there is a treasure Yeti and he's got
tons of treasure and every time you
shoot him treasure is gonna come flying
out of his sack all the teammates are
basically gonna be chasing this guy all
the way around the map meanwhile their
garden is you know being attacked by a
zombies so they got to kind of balance
out how greedy are you gonna get chasing
this guy versus how much do you want to
play the team game and try to protect
your garden one of the big things in the
next DLC is going to be customization
and for this we went crazier than I
think we've ever gone before
the amazing bling pack is going to be
new to the suburban nation DLC it's
gonna have a whole bunch of blinged out
accessories for your characters too
we're talking about gold eye patches
diamond studded pork chops the game is
epic
like just ridiculous ridiculous things
you